welcome everyone it's very nice to see
such large audience at such light time
it's four o'clock and weekend is coming
but it's got so many people who joined
this presentation so I will talk
actually more about using deep learning
based techniques to analyze some aspects
of the football games and there will be
very little about football itself
unfortunately so let's start basically
my name is Jessica Moravsky I work in
the startup company sport algorithmics
with develop a system to analyze
football videos recordings of soccer
games and I also work as an assistant
professor on Warsaw University of
Technology and basically our aim is to
build a system that will help to analyze
videos or recordings of football games
it's intended for professional use for
soccer academies for soccer club clubs
and it's intended to help coaches to
help football analyst to analyze the
soccer videos basically now the work of
the football analysts that work in
football academy or in claw club is
quite cumbersome he needs to manually
watch all the games if he wants for
example to assess performance of certain
player he needs to watch all the game he
needs to look only at the parts when
this player has contact with the ball
and talk on this video only small
fragments of the game were a certain
player did some action for example and
then he need to prepare an assessment of
his performance we would like to
automate the process we would like to
make a system that will track the
players drag the ball where we analyze
the game and find help to find our
interesting aspects of the game like
find automatically situations where
certain player possess the ball when he
kicked the ball when he shoot at the
goal we would like also to computer
automatically compute some statistics
for example how what distance did
I run or how fast did she run on average
what was his maximum speed our
assumption is also that makes the
project much more difficult is to use
off-the-shelf CCTV cameras so we are not
working on the no video broadcast TV
broadcast where these cameras have very
high zoom and you can clearly see the
entire players bother you can see ball
from the close distance we would like to
use the CCTV cameras installed around
the play field so this is the let's say
setup you are working on we've got a
number of fixed cameras installed around
the play field
but basically capture part of the part
of the play see from high distance so we
don't have a good zoom and you would
like to analyze the game unfortunately
yet there is no deep learning system
that will do everything automatically
and there is no big brain that will you
know take as an input video sequence
like that and will automatically output
all the necessary statistics players
rags and so on you need to build it from
smaller components and each component
you can use deep learning techniques to
analyze part of the game for part of the
pipeline so basically the entire
pipeline can be split into three phases
we've got this low level processing
where we detect the ball detect players
jersey recognize number on players
shirts base mid level processing where
we can track the ball in 3d because
using multiple cameras we can track the
ball in 3d tracking and identification
of pliers and also ways with high level
processing where we recognize aspects or
interesting events in the game is this
the pass is this some if someone
shooting at the goal was it the goal and
calculate statistics in this talk I will
concentrate on a few aspects because
it's not sufficient time to discuss
every aspect of the processing I will
talk about bore and prior detection how
we can efficiently do it
and about player tracking how we can
efficiently track players this task like
ball detection well they seem easy for
human okay you watch their game and you
see the ball what the problem but to
write a computer program well we do it
automatically on such high resolution
videos it's not so straightforward first
of all the ball is not always circular
area when it's kicked you've got a
motion blur so it's like a lipstick are
sometimes you can touch the line
sometimes it can touch players body so
you cannot just detect circles because
here you've got the ball touching the
plier and sometimes you are not shown is
this a ball or is this a glove of the
goalkeeper where even human is not sure
what it is detecting players it's a bit
easier because players are usually
bigger but also have got a lot of these
difficult situations like two players
can touch each other and they can have
unusual position you know like falling
or stumbling so also you need to take
care of such situation and how did we
approach this well in terms of object
detection well a lot of generic purpose
object detector already available one of
the most popular ways is this SSD 300
object detector or your object detector
and they are high quality good
performance and they are suited to
detect and large number of objects like
they can detect a dog a cat a dark a car
or a plane like you've got example this
detector you can put an image and it
will give you the bounding box with
probability that this object is a car
umbrella person works by good but
unfortunately for our purpose it's not
sufficient because this is a huge
network it is a huge network it's got
like 30 million parameters it's got
quite impressive performance 60 frames
per second okay more than real-time but
on quite small images 300 by 300 but 9
300 pixel
and we are working on high-resolution
images that got 100 times more pixels so
performance of this generic object
detectors is not sufficient so basically
inspired by this design we build
something simpler but helps but allows
real-time processing of high resolution
videos and the tag ball and player the
design looks like that if you are
interesting in details you can look for
this paper which is going to appear on
the conference in 2020 but should be
available in archive and how it works
basically as the input we take an image
so we've got width height and three
colour channels RGB and the image goes
through this classical convolutional
neural network architecture each of
these block consists of two
convolutional layers and max pooling so
it goes through this convolutional
layers and each of this block produces
the feature map where that's got half of
the image resolution the spatial
resolution is decreased by half and the
number of channels is going up so first
blog is creating the feature map that's
got like weave by 2 right by 2 and so on
I will talk about this part a little bit
later and then output from this feature
Maps is fed to the classifiers
but classify is the ball this is a ball
classifier it classifies is their ball
on this particular part of the screen
which corresponds to this part so we've
got output feature map it goes to the
ball classifier which is a simple
convolutional net work but output ball
confidence map let's code spatial
resolution 1/4 of the width 1/4 of the
height of the original image and one
channel basically value between 0 and 1
and it says ok one says very high
transfer is the ball in this place zero
blue says like leave a snow ball
here the same and supplier football we
don't need a bounding box the ball had
no the same object the same shape almost
yeah it does not vary so much similar
for the player for the player we take
the feature map from the upper
convolutional block which produces
future map of the special smaller
feature map of the special dimension
1/16 of the original image which also
one means a red means very high chance
where is a player at this particular
position which corresponds to the
special positions on the input image
also vice a regresar also simply
convolutional from consisting of two
convolutional layers that regress is
bounding box of the players so it
regress is the position of the bounding
box or the particular location so this
is classical convolutional network
architecture like vgg Norfolk fans and
why this bottom-up top-down connections
this is based on the sphere pyramid
Network concept basically to improve the
quality of the ball detector because if
we don't have this top-down connections
the player detection will work well
without any change because the player
detection takes the input from the text
output from this block goes the player
classifier prior aggressor but when we
go down this channel down this line we
add to the output this convolutional
block we add the higher-level features
but got higher less receptive field and
what it means it means that the ball
classifier does not look only on the
small region around the ball like 20 by
20 pixels but it takes into account the
bigger context without these connections
the ball classifier would only take into
account a small patch in the image like
20 by 20 pixels which be more difficult
to detect the ball if
think is round okay it's likely ball but
it may be you know something part of the
advertisement near the playing field or
maybe some marking some I know marking
on the line or some jitter lying
somewhere but if we add this path then
we take bigger receptive field to
account and the classifier can make
better decision because intuitively can
work in take take into account you know
is this round object yes is something
you know that's looking like a player's
like Mia yes okay well since definitely
ball but if this is something round but
it's not but it's you know around some
study mod ver ties meant it's like
inaudible so this bottom top-down path
improves ball classifier performance I
won't discuss details on the loss
function Hut that works strength but
basically just to give you a feel
feeling how its trained it's fully
supervised training so basically what we
did and this was the most tasks on the
time-consuming tasks we took like a
thousand video frames from real
recordings and manually track the player
position and manually tag ball position
in each of them it was done by a couple
of people took like two or three months
but then we've got a large training set
but we can train our model and it was a
classic stochastic gradient descent
training usual stuff with neural
networks yeah we show the input image it
was passed to the network the network
give us the prediction and we know the
ground truth we've got the ball position
and players position marked you know in
our grant roof data so we compared the
outcome of the network with the ground
truth compute the loss and then use
gradient descent to minimize the loss if
someone is interesting in details and
how this loss function look like you can
look on the for the paper and see the
details and basically training of the
Network took like two days and what are
the results I would say quite good these
are results on the publicly available
data set we use this in our paper so you
can see predictions from the network 99%
confidence but this is the player this
is also quite good you can see here I've
got very quite difficult situation
occlusion the first player is detective
99% but okay the network is Shuba this
is the player the second one is occluded
we've caught like 56 confidence okay low
area because it is occluded so the
network is not sure if this is a player
or not detection of the ball is much
tougher and because there are some
objects like this marking what may look
like a ball so the network has lower
confidence so the confidence level in
this example is like 22% online but the
ball is detected here as well we've got
unusual position this one is lower if
he's that the player is standing the
confidence like 99% because Wednesday
unusual close the network was trained
with the usual pose but if the
goalkeeper takes hands like that where
during the training network says don't
seen the player having hands like that
so it's less confident but this is the
player but 80% is still quite high in
terms of the numerical results the usual
quality measure of object detector is
average precision I mean average
precision so basically this detector on
publicly available ish a soccer dataset
got 90 percent ball detection accuracy
94 player detection accuracy if we don't
use this top-down connections in
detector the ball detection goes down
about 5% so adding this top-down
connections in the network design helps
with especially ball detection with the
player it's almost the same
even better but what's important the
network is very efficient it can operate
on these large high-definition images
1920 by 1080 pixels at almost 40 frames
per second so it's real time almost real
time where as faster as CNN it is a
general-purpose object detector
available in Python for example you can
use it and fine-tune it for your own
purpose it works fine as well but it's
much bigger number of parameters like
100 times more and it operates on 8
frames per second so unselfish and for
real-time processing and to see it in
action
let me show so here some ball detection
we may see that from time to time there
are such ridiculous like on the foot on
players incorrect detections and they
happen so we've got some additional
post-processing steps to actually filter
out with incorrect detections or like
here it look it's something circular
near the players put feet so it was
classified as a ball but very next sport
processing steps but get rid of such
spurious detections
something something's frozen
okay doesn't doesn't want to play so why
we come back to the presentation okay
that the next component I'd like to talk
about is tracking of the players because
so far we detected only pliers but it
was separate detection and each and
every frame we've got a separate
detection these players were not linked
but what do we want to have is to have
tracks of the player to track each
individual prior to the game how he
moves so we can calculate the statistics
the distance here on his speed very
common approach to multi object tracking
is so called tracking by detection and
it works like that so we use this
approach it was like that but we've got
the current track of the object that we
are tracking a colorful person so these
are the positions and appearance of the
object preview tracked so far you know
so we already tracked like in four
consecutive frames with like a player
and then we've got the Texans from the
new frame at time t plus one so we've
got these detection and a new frame and
what we need to do is to much the truck
with the detection here is no-brainer
actually okay we see someone is running
here and detection at time t plus one I
like that so of course yeah this is this
guy no other option actually Pisa blow
so definitely definitely they are if
definitely they are different
this one
this one is white but he is far away so
it's not possible that this one that
that this one matches with this truck
but general watch may have much more
difficult situations like this one here
it's not so easy which one of these
white guys is linked with this truck
because we've got the white player
running through this trajectory and at
time t plus one we've got two detection
but more or less much to this trajectory
so what's the problem that needs to be
solved in this multitasking multi object
tracking but too much trajectories to
detection and you can have more
difficult situation imagine I don't know
free-kick when like maybe five or ten
players just you know squeezing one near
each other and how we can track them in
such rush so basically the approach we
take is like that but we've got the
targets
it means already tracked tracks but we
already know drugs of at previous
timestamps and we've got detection at
the new time step and we want to link
these drugs with detection at the new
time step so what we do is we measure
similarity between the truck and the
resurrection if we go back like here the
similarity is based first of all on the
trajectory in the history yeah on the
previous trajectory and the position of
the detection because okay taking into
account the trajectory and the position
of the player this free somehow similar
to this track because he runs this
trajectory so in the next time step he
may be here here may be here it's all
plausible
but also we take into account the
appearance of the player and in terms of
the appearance okay only this one is
similar to the truck because we've got
the white guy running and based on the
one white here is not so obvious because
here we've got the player running this
trajectory more likely it will be this
one because it's closer to the previous
position and maybe you know taking into
account that he moves at the similar
speed and with a similar acceleration he
likely will be here but it's possible
that he will be here in terms of
appearance well both are quite similar
so we are not sure and there can be much
complex situation so how to address this
in systematic way basically here we
employed deep networks to learn the
features of the truck and to learn this
multi cue multimodal features to compute
assess similarity between the truck and
detection actual is based on the idea
from this paper which explains details
of this process but it basically works
like that but we use recurrent neural
network to first encode the track of the
player taking into account how his speed
changes between consecutive time steps
and we take into account the features
connected with the track and these
features are based basically of
appearance of the player through each
time step we encode this using recurrent
neural networks and then combine both
these motion-based features and
appearance based features and use the
fully connected network to compute the
similarity between these encoded
features from the track and each
detection so we compute similarity
between this truck and each detection
between this track and each detection
this track and each detection and we've
got similarity yeah we've got a
bipartite graph with the similarities
between tracks and the
actions like you are the numbers and now
the task is to join and to merge trucks
with detections to maximize the overall
similarity and this is the classical
algorithm used for this it's called
Hungarian algorithm is very efficient
algorithm basically to march eleventh to
by parrot graphs to maximize to maximize
some measure I won't go into details of
these components they are based
basically on this publication but it
looks like that but to encode the player
appearance we just take the player
bounding boxes from previous detections
pass from CN n convolutional network to
compute features first and then pass the
resultant features for recurrent network
to compute a combined combined
description to combine embedding that
describes the player appearance and then
we use fully connected network to
compare this with the player appearance
in the next time step and similarly with
the most player motion ok I think I'm
running out of time so I will stop at
this moment so other any questions
thanks for their speech I have a
question
have you tried to connect somehow the
videos from the different CCTV cameras
because you told that one cameras is
only a part of the playing card so so so
maybe you should connect the video from
the other cameras to to have have look
at the yeah we take this into account
because in the basics
we've got like four cameras and four
corners two cameras looking at each side
and then we actually when you've got the
sections we project them onto the pitch
onto the plane because the cameras are
calibrated so we can transfer
coordinates from the camera point of
view to the world coordinate system and
we've called we project them onto the
common plane common ground I would say
this is also used for 3d ball position
recovery because then having detecting
the ball from two cameras we can
triangulate the ball position and then
we can compute if the ball then we can
compute the 3d ball coordinates so is
the ball on the ground or is this you
know kick above I know that you haven't
mentioned that part but is the concept
of determining if something is a path
shot or let's say a slide is also based
on the manually labelled data set or do
you have some kind of logic that we
apply there are two approaches one is to
use some simple heuristic I would say
because we can track if we track the
ball and we can track the player we can
see if you know the ball has the contact
with the player if this changed the
trajectory for example and we can based
on the simple heuristic we can classify
if this was a pass for example or
actually a heuristic to detect if it was
a goal is kind of a backward because we
can detect if the ball was placed in the
middle of the playing field and this
means that it had to be you know a goal
earlier when the ball is taken but we
also experiment with the machine
learning based approach but it's still
kind of experimental what about fall if
something is someone falls it's
interesting but at the moment we do not
consider this possibly I think it could
be with the manual labor
data because you need a couple of
examples when the two people are one
people is lying on the ground where the
high chance with
something happened but you cannot
classify you know from this resolution
images you cannot tell if this is was a
fall or someone just stumbled against
his own foot and feet and fell down
do you consider joining other sources of
information to your GPS trackers mm-hmm
there were some experimental GPS
trackers they are used now for track it
to keep track of the players performance
I mean how fast he runs and what the
distance clearance but the spatial
resolution for the subjects that
frequently changed the direction or do
the sudden movement is not sufficient
you've got like then I don't know
a couple of meters it looks better when
the GPS is using the car because you
someone you know use the algorithm to
somehow smooth out the path you know
that the car is not you know jumping
yeah so you can interpolate and smoother
the curve and it's quite accurate but
for the subject wet change the position
very frequently and very quickly it's
not accurate it's like I don't know five
maybe ten meters accuracy so it's not
sufficient to establish it may help with
I don't know maybe with tracking a
little bit but it's not sufficient to
tell if someone has a contact with a
ball or not
you do try to use less than four cameras
to 3d trick I mean two are necessary I
haven't tried this I've read one paper
with someone use one camera to establish
frida position of the ball doing
trajectory analysis because if the ball
goes like you know parabola movement it
means it has to be kicked up and down or
maybe someone you know do the streak and
kick the ball give the rotation and its
piece on the ground but goes like
parabola so but usually the parabola
that the parabolic trajectory indicates
vets in the air but we haven't tried
this did you try to use pose estimation
you try to use pose yeah yeah yeah there
were some experiments with this yeah we
let say in the production system we are
we've had such functionality for players
do you use only 2d tricking or also try
to trick drums in 3d try to trick Tori's
for players no other players you want to
do today because this 3d is you know
very frequent so we assume they are on
the playing ground okay sometimes
someone can jump and fly with the head
but okay it will be some error than
position estimation but we'd say accept
it thank you
you said to have some problems with the
ball recognition because of the of the
field
have you tried to filter out the field I
would say in production system we've got
certain post-processing steps basically
when clean these results and this is one
of them to just filter the field out so
to only then focus on the detection
within the play field yeah that's one of
the steps because as you seen very very
couple of fault detections like the ball
is detected where the player fit is and
so this needs to be and also sometimes
we've got like spare balls lying near
the playing field especially in the
training game so this all must be
filtered out we do it after recognition
because you know sometimes when you've
got like ball butts kicked
outside the playing field we don't want
to lose it immediately because sometimes
it's kicked outside and we want at least
to keep track of it at least to see that
you know but it goes outside the city
trajectory so we don't want to
rigorously cut out the field thanks
you mentioned detecting the player
numbers from the jerseys so how well
does that actually work and can you for
example track player statistics in
practicing depends on the resolution of
videos with these videos it's extremely
difficult to recognize majority numbers
so in the setup when you've got more
cameras like maybe six cameras two
additional cameras at the side of the
field then you can detect jersey numbers
better I would say okay
could you repeat what's the size of your
data set and how diverse is it how many
films labelled films you have for our
purpose we use the data set that got
about a about 8,000 frames from
different matches from different playing
fields to provide a diversity and these
were matches by the professional
football clubs but it was not a
constitute if you are we because in the
consecutive video usually I've got the
same lighting you know the same Jersey
colors so we would like to provide
diversity so it were just selected
frames from a number of matches to
provide a diversity because if we train
this on 8,000 frames from one match and
then there you know where different
jerseys it will fail very likely because
they haven't seen guys if for example
there were different lighting conditions
it will also very likely fail so the
diversity of the data is key thank you I
guess this is thank you very much thank
you
[Applause]
you